les nouveaux maîtres de l'egypte
s'explique
hosni moubarak en exclusivité sur
antenna l'assassinât du juge à marseille
la piste italienne quand on est riche
face aux pauvres
demain aux assises de l'isère les
français matencio où les brigades rouges
à la française 24 heures madame monsieur
bonsoir 24 heures après l'assassinât en
pleine rue à marseille du juge pierre
michel les milieux de la magistrature de
la police est aussi les milieux
politiques donnent libre cours à leur
émotion et à leur indignation
le premier ministre pierre mauroy a
demandé au ministre de l'inde de
l'intérieur et au ministre de la justice
d'étudier de nouvelles mesures de
protection des magistrats à paris le
premier président de la cour d'appel et
le procureur général demande aux
magistrats d'apprécier eux mêmes les
moyens convenables pour manifester
publiquement leur sentiment le dossier
de l'assassinât a été confiée
aujourd'hui au juge d'instruction pierre
guérin le mari de madame laurence guérin
qui instruit la sphère d'auriol sur
place à marseille
corinne pertuis depuis midi et jusqu'à
lundi matin 9h le tribunal de marseille
est fermé
les magistrats ne donne aucune audience
sauf en référé en signe de deuil
autour du palais on continue à discuter
en iran unanimement hommage au juge
michel malgré les inimitiés que ces
méthodes en suisse y pêcher les deux
d'un juge à la fois très remarquablement
intelligent très courageux et qui
s'engageait personnellement dans ces
dossiers ce qu'il va être très souvent
de l'accrochage avec les avocats
parce que chacun faisant son métier et
le faisan à fond avec passion il n'y
avait pas de concessions
ceci étant c'était un magistrat
infiniment d'estimables parce qu'il ne
s'est jamais comporté comme un
gestionnaire de la justice il avait une
vision très moral de son métier il s'y
engageait comme un homme à fond et à ce
niveau là on doit avoir le plus grand
respect pour la façon dont il se
comportait son comportement ses méthodes
étaient à l'image de cet homme de 38 ans
acerbes agressif efficace dans ses
dossiers qu'il fonçait mais pour lui il
ne prenait aucune pression il y à midi
comme tous les jours il a pris le même
chemin
prix de son bureau tout près du palais
de justice devait l'amener chez lui dans
le quartier sainte anne
il ne changerait jamais dit merrer une
habitude dangereuse pour un homme menacé
michel avait parfaitement conscience qui
s'occupait d'affaires difficile qu'il
avait affaire à des adversaires dont les
intérêts étaient importants et
ne recule devant aucun moyen pour se
débarrasser de quelqu'un qui peut gêner
mais il ne se sentait pas
particulièrement menacé ces derniers
temps du moins ne s'attirent livret a
personne pour ce sujet on dit qu'ils
étaient armés
non ma connaissance il n'est pas armé
hantée même lorsque certains mais
conseillé de porter une arme il ne
prenait donc aucune mesure de sécurité
est ce que ce n'est pas une erreur
d'après vous dans les juges n'ont pas à
être armés et la verità protection des
juges c'est d'une part la loi ce sont
des machines à appliquer la loi et
d'autre part l'institution
juju n'est qu'un mai et ne devrait être
qu'un rouage dans une institution si
l'institution fonctionne comme elle doit
fonctionner les rouages sont
interchangeables et à cet égard on peut
peut-être regretter
l'extrême personnalisation
de cette fonction à marseille
pour les magistrats la solution pour
leur assurer une plus grande sécurité
serait donc de ne pas confier au même
juge toutes les affaires de grand
banditisme
une trop grande spécialisation et sans
doute l'erreur fondamentale de cette
affaire sans cette erreur
l'avis du michel ne se serait peut-être
pas arrêté au pied de ce platane
la police française a envoyé à palerme
en sicile un premier rapport informel
sur l'assassinât en effet depuis un an
car michel travailler en collaboration
étroite avec deux magistrats sicilien
sur les liens entre la pègre
marseillaise et les trafiquants de
drogue de la mafia de rome victor
vraiment il faut absolument rappeler une
chose c'est qu'il est un peu plus d'un
an maintenant
une enquête menée conjointement par les
polices française italienne permettait
de découvrir en sicile un laboratoire
clandestin qui était en mesure de
fabriquer 500 kg d'héroïne par mois il
eu à cette époque trente cinq
arrestations
aussi bien en france qu'en italie or il
semble bien que ce réseau qui alimente
le marché américain de la drogue n'a pas
été complètement démantelée et comme le
confirme le directeur du service italien
antidrogue
c'est une vaste enquête qui est menée
actuellement aussi bien en france qu'en
italie et cela expliquerait pas mal de
choses dans ce projet ce qu on ne peut
pas exclure qu'il y ait des
développements à bref délai il y aurait
donc encore un lien entre marseille et
la sicile
bassil et la sicile je ne suis pas en
mesure de vous le dire
et d'ailleurs je ne suis pas autorisé à
vous le dire il y à une enquête de la
police judiciaire
je ne peux pas vous dire ce que font en
ce moment les policiers les juges
disons qu'on continue de travailler
intensément
est ce que ce n'est pas cette enquête
qui expliquerait la mort du juge de
marseille
ce n'est pas moi qui peux l'affirmer
michel mais il est certain que le juge
michel avait cette enquête entre les
mains et qu'il s'en occupe et d'une
façon approfondie les obsèques du juge
pierre michel auront lieu vendredi dans
l'intimité
le président de la république a envoyé
ce soir un télégramme à sa veuve
par delà le drame qui vous frappe et la
teinte que ces crimes odieux porte à la
magistrature
la disparition de votre mari touche la
france tout entière écrit donc le chef
de l'état à madame michèle l'homme du
jour sur antenne 2 le nouveau maître de
l'egypte le président hosni moubarak
c'est aux correspondants permanents
d'antenne 2 au caire pierre serra que le
président moubarak vient en effet
d'accorder la première interview qu'il
donne à la presse française une
interview où vous allez le voir le
nouveau raïs ne mâche pas ses mots il a
le langage de son physique tout en force
pas question de remettre en cause comme
des vides et les accords avec israël
notamment sur la question de l'autonomie
palestinienne de paris
wilbur wright phillips which we did the
days est fait l'écho des communes de cap
des hévéas ma prise de conscience propre
est celle où ils vivent et frenzel chose
adopte présence des forces de piste
grosses icônes cloud et conclut de
l'icann tv oui à florina les cadets vite
concerner le folotyn sûreté jérusalem et
asada des défenseurs y voit non oui
stage des bleus monde plus sûr vers
celle ci une fourmi de boutons réseau
mpls arabe sauveteurs piste witty
between israel and egypt which the
fighting sioux dhabi n'est donc
probablement oui des odeurs arras à
l'epita gagnent des tweeds et laines
civile et she is that we do el kaf
diplomatique les fils secret files al
horford peace boat fasse des efforts
le jeune juriste or m après donc les
états au havre où vivait la famille ni à
fixe tous et elle est douce au monde
oui
fx match face au nahd
après des premiers secours aux familles
aux fans de halo français d'après des
modèles acceptent de baisser encore à la
traîne en dv fine torpeur faites les
vivre une relation vraiment drôle
une preuve de la continuité de la
politique égyptienne
les experts égyptiens israéliens et
américains ont repris aujourd'hui à tel
aviv leurs discussions sur l'autonomie
palestinienne
et puis un signal d'alarmé tiré par
jérusalem un véritable pont aérien
fonctionnerait entre la syrie et la
libye pour acheminer à tripoli
d'importantes quantités de matériel
militaire et renforcer ainsi le colonel
kadhafi face à la nouvelle détermination
égyptienne et américains les deux tiers
de l'humanité réunis autour d'une table
ronde de 10 mètres de large à cancun le
sommet et nord-sud a commencé
aujourd'hui après le dîner de travail
qui a réuni hier les 22 chefs d'état et
de gouvernement le risque d'une
confrontation ouverte entre les
etats-unis et les autres pays à
commencer par la france semble atténuer
que peuvent être maintenant les
résultats de ce sommet sans précédent
disons que l'humeur sur place est à
l'optimisme prudent
bernard benyamin cette première journée
du sommet de cancun a été en fait pour
beaucoup une prise de contact très
importante
en marge du dialogue nord-sud on a pu
voir par exemple françois mitterrand
rencontré le président algérien chadli
pendant plus d'une heure
et il ya fort à parier que les deux
hommes ont parlé du prochain voyage du
président français en algérie à la fin
du mois de novembre
ce sont donc 22 chefs d'état et de
gouvernement qui se sont retrouvés tout
à l'heure pour la science inaugurale de
la conférence de cancun
une assez longue séance au cours de
laquelle les chefs de délégation ont eu
10 minutes chacun pour expliquer leur
point de vue et c'est tout pour les
centaines de journalistes qui couvrent
la conférence aucun communiqué officiel
ne sera diffusé à l'issue des deux jours
de réunion
il y aura seulement une conférence de
presse des deux coprésidents le mexicain
lopez portillo et le canadien pierre
elliott trudeau
cela dit on a pu voir aussi aujourd'hui
un ronald reagan en pleine forme en polo
rouge et pantalon de toile
le président américain a donné
l'impression de vouloir travailler et
travailler vite pour un nouvel ordre
économique international poursuite des
travaux demain et discussions entre
autres du projet français qui veut
mettre en place une coopération
internationale globale pour mieux
répartir les ressources du monde à
anvers aujourd'hui plus de 5000
personnes juives et non juives ont
manifesté leur solidarité aux victimes
de l'attentât antisémite d'avant-hier
toutes les associations juives de
belgique étaient représentés tous les
partis politiques et toutes les couches
de la population
c'était le recueillement mais aussi la
protestation
la police affirme ce soir tenir une
piste sérieuse en collaboration avec les
polices étrangères
les portraits robots du couple qui a
loué la camionnette piégée vont être
distribués l'homme aurait un passeport
maltais ou chypriotes
le fait du jour en france reste la
démission de pierre moussa le président
de la banque de paris et des pays bas
une démission qui fait date
à quelques heures après le vote de la
loi nationalisant son groupe surtout par
la virulence des commentaires du pouvoir
hier c'était le ministre de l'économie
jacques delors qui accusait monsieur
moussa de ne pas avoir rempli ses
engagements
aujourd'hui c'est au tour du premier
ministre pierre mauroy il y a des lois
pour tous les citoyens et personne ne
peut y échapper
si on essaye de s'y soustrait de se
soustraire à ce pardon si on essaie de
soustraire ce qui était à paris va
certaines de ses activités
jeudi c'est le premier ministre qui
parle que monsieur moussa ne se comporte
pas comme citoyen doit se comporter
il a une mentalité d'émigrer et ceci est
très grave
fin de citation une mentalité d'émigrer
ce mort on n'y va pas de main morte
pierre-marie travier thiaville quel est
donc ce contentieux d'abord entre le
gouvernement et monsieur moussa bâ ce
contentieux d'abord il s'appelle
nationalisation parce que pierre moussa
y étaient opposés qui s'appelle surtout
paribas suisse et l'or c'est une
importante filiale de paribas est c'est
officiel depuis quelques heures cette
filiale viennent passer sous le contrôle
d'un groupe de sociétés et
d'investisseurs étrangers
ce groupe s'appelle pargesa il a été
constitué spécialement pour ça à genève
on y trouve des américains des belges
des suisses tous partenaires de longue
date de paribas alors je vous fais grâce
de l'offre publique d'achat de des
participations croisées
ce qu'il faut retenir c'est que
l'assemblée nationale vient de voter la
nationalisation de paribas mais que
depuis cet après midi il en manque un
morceau alors colère du gouvernement
sabotage économique mauvais citoyen
émigré pour un plan n'accuserai pierre
moussa de haute trahison alors même même
sans aller si loin ce qu'on a entendu
aujourd'hui c'est quand même beaucoup
pour un grand banquier qui apparemment
n'a rien commis d'illégal dans la valeur
est reconnue par tout le monde et qui
par dessus le marché est un ancien
conseiller de pierre mendès-france
envoyé d'autre part même sans sa filiale
suisse même sans cette filiale paribas
suisse paribas nationaliser pourrait
largement être le puissant d'outils
financiers dont veut se doter de se
doter l'état alors en fait cette fuite
parce qu'on peut appeler ça une fuite de
la filiale suisse échappe à la
nationalisation c'est plutôt perçu par
le gouvernement peut être comme un
camouflet qu'elle communique catastrophe
alors c'est peut-être cela je crois qui
a justifié ou qui explique la gravité
elle est la rare violence des
qualificatifs d'autres gratifications
moussa le gouvernement a le sentiment
d'avoir été roulé pierre moussa dit j'ai
essayé d'empêcher l'opération je n'ai
pas réussi et c'est pourquoi je
démissionne le gouvernement répond pas
du tout c'est vous qui avait tout
organisé vous avez fait passer des
intérêts privés et étrangers de surcroît
avant le service de l'état et ça c'est
intolérable
alors c'est un procès qui pourrait durer
comme ça a duré longtemps mais
finalement il devenu un paix sans objet
aujourd'hui puisque premièrement pierre
moussa n'est plus le patron de paribas
deuxièmement paribas suisse n'appartient
plus aux europe depuis cet après midi et
troisièmement la nationalisation du
reste de paribas est inéluctable
l'envoyer accusations et justifications
maintenant à scène ça ne pourra plus
changer grand chose même si quelqu'un a
triché
maintenant les jeux sont faits est ce
que c'est un exemple qui pourrait être
suivi par d'autres groupes nationalistes
certains le grain mais je ne pense plus
que ce sera aussi facile maintenant en
tout cas une affaire qui empoisonne un
peu plus encore le débat sur les
nationalisations qui vous le savez a
gravement détérioré les rapports
majorité opposition hier le premier
secrétaire du parti socialiste lionel
jospin a minimisé le rôle éventuel du
conseil constitutionnel la juridiction
suprême à laquelle l'opposition
envisagent de recourir pour prouver
l'illégalité du projet de loi une cour
suprême a dit monsieur jospin n'a jamais
arrêté les grands courants de réformes
le secrétaire général du rpr vient d'en
appeler au président de la république
bernard pons demande au chef de l'état
je cite de faire cesser ces excès d
dissiper ces tentatives d'intimidation
qui sont indignes d'une démocratie
si la constitution est violée par
acharnement partisans sous-entendait si
l'avis du conseil constitutionnel ne
fait pas autorité que restera-t-il de
nos libertés demande monsieur pons à
l'assemblée nationale le dit daniel
brême cinq articles du projet de loi ont
été adoptés cet après-midi un record les
socialistes ont renoncé à leur temps de
parole pour aller plus vite
en revanche le sénat a repoussé le
projet des nationalisations de la
sidérurgie
cet appel de monsieur pons au président
d'un public pour qu'il est clair ou
infirme les propos du chef de son propre
parti le parti socialiste illustre en
tout cas de façon exemplaire le thème
qui à partir de demain à valence va
occuper tous les élus et tous les cadres
du parti socialiste quel est le rôle du
parti socialiste au pouvoir et face au
pouvoir
si les courants ne sont plus à la mode
quel mode de fonctionnement trouvé entre
parti godillot est parti rebelle déjà
entre le parti proprement dit le groupe
parlementaire et le pouvoir c'est à dire
le gouvernement et l'elysée il ya eu des
exemples de friction notre dossier du
jour patrice urgent de l'est
depuis les élections les rapports entre
le parti socialiste le groupe et le
gouvernement oscille entre l'épreuve de
force c'est la réconciliation des deux
côtés on découvre l'exercice du pouvoir
et les hommes doivent concilier
l'efficacité et le débat démocratique
d'où de multiples rencontres pour tenter
de trouver des compromis
lionel jospin voit ainsi le président de
la république
deux fois par semaine quant au premier
ministre pierre mauroy et bien il a dû
affronter le groupe socialiste à propos
de l'énergie et il a usé de toute son
autorité pour convaincre les
parlementaires réticents de la nécessité
de six centrales nucléaires
un autre exemple tous les mercredis
soirs à 19h se réunit le bureau exécutif
du parti socialiste les ministres y
défilent pour expliquer leur politique
et la discussion y est souvent en très
vive avec tous ces responsables de la
rue de solférino et de même face au
groupe socialiste laurent fabius devra
défendre son budget contesté sur de
nombreux points par ces nouveaux députés
sur le fond maintenant voyons d'abord
comment l'elysée et son secrétaire
général envisage dans cette affaire le
rôle de chacun dans notre démocratie il
faut pas y avoir de confusion sous
aucune forme
entre le parti et l'état c'est vrai la
marche de manoeuvre pour le parti
socialiste est très étroite
il doit faire face aux réalités du
pouvoir sans être traité deux parties
godille
il faut que les français se rendent
compte que c'est du débat c'est de d'un
échange vivant entre le gouvernement et
les formations représentées au parlement
à la majorité le parti socialiste qui a
la majorité absolue à lui tout seul que
peut être la définition d'une bonne
politique pour la france et non pas d'un
gouvernement qui donne des ordres et qui
est obéit ou d'un parti qui s'adjugeait
tirait le gouvernement c'est pas comme
ça c'est une relation vivante
c'est du groupe socialiste qu'il faut
attendre la plus grande indépendance
même si ses membres doivent respecter la
règle d'unités de vote sur plusieurs
projets de loi en effet certains députés
se sont fait entendre sur les immigrés
l'énergie bientôt sur le budget ils
reconnaissent qu'ils ne sont pas
totalement d'accord avec le gouvernement
jusqu'à présent celui ci s'est félicité
de ce débat interne
ce sont des hommes libres à des pierre
mauroy les raisons de cette discussion
sont simples loin du faste de
l'assemblée dans leur circonscription
des élus sont interpellés par les
militants confronter avec les problèmes
sociaux
regardez dans la seine saint denis
véronique neiertz nouvel élu doit se
battre contre le chômage dans cette
agence pour l'emploi il faut trois
semaines pour se faire inscrire foot de
personnel un gouvernement au pouvoir a
toujours cours toujours un risque
d'isolement quelques assure vous déjà
actuellement c'est toujours une
tentation c'est toujours un risque
surtout lorsque dans un gouvernement il
y a beaucoup de technocrates
nous nous sommes des hommes de terrain
nous les élus nous sommes en contact
avec la réalité et nous servons
justement de liaison entre un
gouvernement qui est occupé avec les
tâches de responsabilité du pouvoir et
ce qui se passe sur le terrain ce que la
population nous dit et vit tous les
jours
vigilance critique les députés
socialistes ont bien l'intention de
faire fonctionner l'assemblée et il y un
jour conflit avec le gouvernement
c'est sans doute le président la
république qui tranchera le congrès du
parti qui se réunit donc à valence
demain jusqu'à dimanche doit être sous
le signe de l'unité le point de départ
d'une vaste mobilisation selon lionel
jospin qui sera reconduit dans ses
fonctions de premier secrétaire
renault billancourt étaient dans la rue
ce matin fidèle à sa tradition le
haut-lieu ouvriers de
boulogne-billancourt a organisé un grand
cortège de protestation à l'appel de
l'intersyndicale
plusieurs milliers de travailleurs
étaient dans la rue avec martine gilson
on était plus dans un monde où cela a
mené jusqu'à bihan pour réclamer tout à
la fois la fin du chômage technique
l'augmentation des salaires et la
retraite à 55 ans nous voulons moins
suivi d'après la direction que la
semaine passée
13h et banderoles replier les renault
comme on les appelle se retrouve à la
conduire et commente la matinée j'ai vu
pas mal de retard
les migrants avaient développé il ya
aussi les états
vous avez débrayé ce matin
jusqu'ici ça n'a servi à rien ce
débrayage est bien mais on espère bien
que je suis là d'aujourd'hui s'ajoutant
aux autres ça va commencer à servir à
quelque chose parce que c'est évident
c'est à désespérer si la régie
convaincre il faut garder le chercheur
que en gros depuis depuis le 10 mai dans
ce pays et des choses pour changer mais
pour les secteurs nationalisés comme
nous l'avait relayé rien qui a changé
je crois qu il
il ya délit d légitime impatience comme
on est impatient ce partage est
apparemment
depuis le début de ce conflit vont ils
pouvoir tout la perte que la direction a
déjà eu
et si la direction veut bien vendre ses
voitures et bien bon il faudra qu'elle
vienne négocier sérieusement
sinon nous apprendre à manier
ce soit fin du cac et direction sont
réunis pour une rencontre prévue de
longue date
on ne sait pas encore si l'on parlait
des revendications
en attendant depuis le 2 octobre pas une
seule r4 nous sort de l'île seguin
georges marchais ira demain aux usines
renault billancourt s'adresser aux
ouvriers rappelez vous cela se passait
il ya cinq ans à grenoble un tueur un
tueur fou terrorisé la région narguer la
police et au nom d'un groupe mystérieux
les brigades rouges 666 assassiné et
réclamait rançon
joël matin sio trente trois ans va
comparaître à partir de demain devant
les assises de l'isère
il avait été confondu à cause de sa voix
l'afer est un vrai roman policier paul
lefèvre la ferme attention se résume
s'articule dans ce document l'accusation
autour de quatre visages les deux
premiers les voici
christian leroy 25 ans muriel ferrari 21
ans
ces cartes d'identité accompagnée une
demande de rançon 350 millions de
centimes que voici signé brigades rouges
666 on était le 19 juin 76 la ferme
attention commencé avec l annonce de
l'enlèvement de ce couple dont on devait
retrouver la voiture une semaine plus
tard dans les bois sur la route de
chamrousse
entre temps les messages les coups de
téléphone des ravisseurs
toujours la même voix d'ailleurs se
multiplier l'interlocuteur privilégié
semblait texte monsieur qui me pierre
chirol une commune périphérique de
bringue votants c'est l'état le ton
s'est durci c'est la rançon augmenter sa
rentrée à détériorer le climat grenoble
où la police apparemment impuissante
multiplier les contrôles à recherche de
ces fameuses brigades rouges 666
troisième visage
le voici old boys nico alors qu'un
message venait d'annoncer l'exécution
par pendaison de muriel ferrari de
christian leroy
un homme masqué et armé surgit le 23
juillet 76 auprès d'un couple de fiancés
qui s'était isolée dans la campagne
olga molsheim qu'au 21 ans est obligé de
ligoter son fiancé puis de suivre
l'inconnu
personne ne le reverra plus jamais
durant tout l'été 76 les brigades rouges
666 semble narguer la police et y
prendre plaisir semer la terreur ici
complaire les messages s'additionnent
parfois incohérents parfois étranges
ainsi réclamant la gratuité des
transports urbains à grenoble où des
distributions de vivres aux indigents
par les grands magasins nouveaux défis
sinistre le 1er octobre 76 un plan dans
une lettre permet de retrouver ici près
de saint martin d'uriage les corps
enfouis sous des branchages de christian
leroy et de muriel ferrari ils sont
morts depuis longtemps sans doute depuis
le jour de leur enlèvement mais personne
ne peut précisément dire comment par qui
et où le 16 octobre 76 toutes les radios
et les télévisions diffusent cet
enregistrement de la voix qui
transmettait les messages voilà donc cet
enregistrement destiné à permettre de
mettre un nom et un visage sur cet homme
un enregistrement qui je vous le
rappelle date de quelques mois avant la
découverte des deux premiers meurtres en
effet un message vais lire le juge
qu'ils feront donc le futur à ce moment
là je montre ben oui qu'il faudra les
instructions aux mains voila tu trouves
ans les instructions par les toilettes
au moins d'accord dans la soute
m d'accord d'accord rêver à 10 heures du
soir le même jour jean pierre fernandez
gardien de la paix à grenoble se
présenter à la police judiciaire
j'ai reconnu la voix disait-il c'est
celle de mon beau frère joël matencio je
ne sais pas où il est dans la nuit le
père et les soeurs de joel madden sio
confirmé marie et on a reconnu la voix
de mon frère joel madden sio quatrième
bizarre 28 ans marié 3 enfants garçons
de café plusieurs fois condamné déjà
impliqué dans l'assassinât à lyon en 74
d'un richissime hôtelier yves marin la
flèche le juge françois renault l'avait
inculpé puis relâché faute de preuves
après quelques mois de prison quelques
jours d'ailleurs avant d'être lui-même
assassiné par des inconnus jamais
retrouvé largement allégé wistron
pêchant dois je faire criminel de cette
gravité de son retentissement il est
clair que tu ne fonctionnera pas et demi
en vigueur
quatre jours plus tard recherché par
toutes les polices de france joël
batteux souhaitent arrêter à paris
d'abord il nie tout ensuite il
s'installe dans un système de défense
qui n'a pas varié
oui dit il où il est écrit mais je
téléphonais mais je les fais sous la
menace de cinq personnes qui étaient des
brigades rouges 666 voilà tous
l'accusent
sauf qu il est vrai qu'il n'existait pas
de preuve directe de sa participation ou
trois meurtres trois meurtres de plus
tôt car le corps d'olga borissenko n'a
jamais été retrouvé ainsi personne ne
peut jurer qu'elle soit morte
sauf matencio s'il parle une dépêche qui
tombe à l'instant le président
mitterrand vient de se prononcer pour
l'envoi au tchad d'une force à terre
africaine
c'est donc un communiqué qui nous vient
de cancun
le président français vient de demander
au président en exercice de
l'organisation de l'unité africaine le
président du kenya d'envoyer de toute
urgence une force au tchad le tchad je
vous le rappelle est occupée par les
troupes libyennes
les résultats du kart et maintenant vous
deviez